them things are lovely fireworks ma'am
it's an invasion curses I'm kidding them
I'm killing them take the block is a
movie about a gang of British teenage
kids who protect their apartment complex
building from an alien invasion it
doesn't get nerd into a happy home with
Reese's Pieces it gets dealt with the
way you would get dealt with if you
attacked the character of Moses who's
the main character of our film what
Moses our strong and silent character
character that has more internal than
external he's very pissed about he's
going with his buddies family and you
meet him out of point where he's trying
to make two decisions well it's gonna
rattle one part and all of that is just
interrupted by this big alien invasion
where he has to find the good and
insults and get some summarized soil at
arm's length and defeat these savage
beasts yeah
strictly hood you know this movie's an
executive produced by Edgar Wright who
directives from the dead and halt
positive Scott Pilgrim and I told him I
was going to do a movie with a cast of
young actors who've never been on screen
before with night shoots with creature
effects with stunts with explosions and
a dog so basically he said Joey you know
you're doing everything that you
shouldn't do you're making it as hard as
for yourself as as possible and that
made me scared but it also made me
excited because I knew if we pulled it
off we been doing stuff that people
didn't usually attempt to do and that
included the monsters as well you know
the design of the creatures because when
we were raising the money the first
thing they asked was you know yeah this
is a good idea I can see this movie is
it like a 2030 million
pound production but how are you going
to do this for the kind of media budget
that we would raise so yeah we ended up
using this hopefully quite innovative
technique and it's the technique for the
creatures is based on memories of
rotoscope
when I was a kid I went to see Ralph
after his Lord of the Rings and I went
to see an exhibition about it on earth
on a barge in the Thames and it it
showed how rotoscope worked
they shot live-action on an empty set
then they paint over the live-action it
becomes kind of a contemporary version
of like an old version of motion capture
and I thought well they've never blended
that with actual live-action actors
before that's kind of what we're doing
with lots of other enhancements but it
is a technique a visual technique that I
don't think anyone's tried there are
animatronic elements there are puppetry
elements and there are animation
elements this is kind of a comic book
movie and we approached it visually like
a graphic novel but I really think these
aliens are unlike anything you've seen
before you know we made a very
deliberate attempt to put something new
on screen maybe there was a party at the
zoo and the monkey shagged a fish
filmgoers sometimes I feel that monsters
in movies are quite similar you know a
dragon from Harry Potter could wander
into mova field and you wouldn't really
know the difference and I love I love
Empire Strikes Back you know I love
gremlins and et obviously and those are
practical effects they were puppetry and
they got a more organic kind of human or
third feel to them I used to like
drawing the monsters I used to like
drawing creatures I'd seen and you tried
drawing a Harry Potter dragon no you
need a fine art degree in a way attack
the block is a reaction to other movies
that have betrayed these kids as kind of
bum
you know bestial and barrel and
animalistic you know certain movies have
a very negative portrayal of those kids
so we start with that negative betrayal
but this event actually gives the kids a
chance to show that their dimensional
rounded human beings and we took care to
show that they're proud of where they
live and there's a sci-fi beauty to
where they live you know one of the
things that interested me about that
architecture was that it was built you
know after the Second World War and in
the 50s and 60s in a spirit of massive
optimism you know and cinematically that
kind of architecture in metropolis or
Logan's Run or proper Goron's
it's seen as futuristic and optimistic
and aspirational and I wanted to bring
back that sci-fi feel you know we treat
our tower block as if it's the Nostromo
or the Nakatomi Plaza or the Poseidon or
something it's a it's a science
fictional space and you know I think I
think well I did a lot of research for
this movie and talking to kids who live
in those places they loved the
architecture they're not bombing across
those walkways on their bikes they love
chasing down the corridors so our our
block might as well be a spaceship
that's how we approached it